a yoga teacher police constable and
businesswoman just three of 300 women
who are taking part in a two-year
round-the-world research mission into
ocean plastics
people from 30 nationalities will join
the boat at different legs sky ocean
rescue ambassador Emily 10 he's heading
up the expedition I think I realized
working on this plastics problem is that
there's no silver bullet solution for
solving the issue but that the great
news is there are hundreds of things we
can be doing but to bring those
solutions to life we need people from
all different skill sets and backgrounds
and expertise and so we need scientists
alongside artists and teachers and
designers and policy makers and industry
leaders to work on those solutions among
those on board is Kirsty young he's
swapping her day job as a firearms
officer in London for two weeks at sea
it's the fact that it's so to turn an
ordinary person like me it's so unseen
and you know I do my very own recycle
but other than other than that really
going out there and actually seen it for
myself and hopefully being shocked by
what I see and the results that we get
on the boat
I'm really hoping that will encourage me
to go back and tell my story the
all-female expedition will set sail from
Plymouth the ten guests and four crew
will first head to the Azores two and a
half weeks away in total the journey
will take in 30 destinations spanning
38,000 nautical miles dozens of
different experiments will be carried
out during the trip some of the
scientific tests will be done right here
on the boat so they can analyze the
results instantly on the ocean plastics
other samples will be sent back to land
for further tests the team hopes bring
people from all backgrounds onboard will
bring fresh solutions to tackling ocean
plastics
damn I said Sky News in Plymouth